يقول بعض الناس أن الخاسر فقط
سيجلس وينتظر في طابور ماذا تقول
لهم أقول لهم
اذهب إلى الجحيم أو تعال واجلس هنا مع
بقيتنا
[موسيقى]
إذا كنت تريد أكثر الأدوات عالية التقنية
ما تحتاجه أمي  لإحضار كرسي ذو تقنية منخفضة ،
سأحتاج إلى كرسي مثل كرسي قابل للطي
أحضرته إلى المخيم ، إنه مخيم
في الشارع الخامس في نيويورك مما يقضي الوقت على
الهواتف المحمولة القديمة بينما ينتظرون
iPhone ينتظرون أيامًا يقولها البعض
فقط  سيجلس الخاسر وينتظر في طابور
ماذا تقول
لهم أقول لهم
اذهب إلى الجحيم أو تعال واجلس هنا مع
بقيتنا.
ساعة أبل ستور
تعيش على التبرعات التي تتراوح من
كرات الجبن إلى مزيل العرق إلى قطعتين من الهوت دوغ
وبيبسي ، يمكنك قراءة كل شيء
عنها في أول سطر في مدونة جريج لمدونة آيفون
لماذا تريد iPhone كثيرًا ، لا أنا لا
صديقي يفعل ذلك  أنا جالس
هنا كان يمكن أن يدفع لشخص
ما يعرضه جليسة الأطفال  خدماتهم
مقابل مئات الدولارات مع بدء
العد التنازلي لساعة iPhone ليوم الجمعة ،
يستطيع هؤلاء الأشخاص الجلوس هنا طوال الأسبوع بدون عمل ،
لا شيء ، أنا طالب يقضون نصف
وقتهم في إجراء المقابلات بالنسبة
للمراجعات التي يتوهجونها بالفعل تستحق
الشهوة  بعد أن يقول الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية اليوم
ومن نيويورك تايمز يفعل أشياء لم
يفعلها أي هاتف على الإطلاق ، وهو ما
كان مازح عنه كونان أوبراين في إعلان
وهمي ، فتاحة زجاجات
، وشفرة حلاقة كهربائية ، ومجفف شعر ، ومصيدة فئران ، ومجدفون على هاتف
آيفون ، يطلقون عليها اسم
هاتف المسيح المزاح.  إذا كانت هذه هي المرة الثانية التي
تلهم المزيد من الإعلانات التجارية الوهمية ،
فما الذي كان ينتظره أولئك الذين ينتظرون في طابور قائلين
هللويا أكثر من غيرهم بدوا أكثر تأثرًا
بشاشة لمس iPhone إذا كنت
تريد قلب الصفحة ، فما عليك سوى
النقر فوقها ، يمكنني النقر فوقها يسارًا أو يمينًا
للتمرير إلى  الصورة التالية
يمكنني تكبيرها عن طريق
تصغير الصورة وتحريكها عن طريق سحب
هذه الأشياء بتكلفة خمسمائة وستمائة دولار
من يدفع ثمن جهاز iPhone الخاص بك ، من الذي
تعتقده بشأن والديّ بشكل واضح  لكن
هل يعرفون ذلك حتى الآن ، ولكن إذا كنت
لا تستطيع شراء جهاز iPhone ، فهناك دائمًا
هذا
القطع والطي في جهاز iPhone ، يتم
تداول الفصل على الويب ، فقط قم بطيه على
هاتفك الخلوي القديم الرابع في السطر ولكن
أولاً سيكون لديك جهاز iPhone بعد ذلك مباشرة  بزوغ الفجر ،
كان هناك رجل جاء
وقال إن أي شخص يشتري جهاز iPhone
سيساعده هو أن أي طريقة للتحدث
عن جني هاتف المسيح في الغالب cnn new
york
[موسيقى]
أنت